[Musique]
j'ai un sentiment de satisfaction enfin
le gouvernement a entendu nos arguments
aient changé d'avis depuis quelques mois
en décidant de des conjugue elysées
l'allocation adulte handicapé alors
c'est vrai que c'est un vieux combat
plus de deux ans que nous menions virer
cette démarche d'initiative avec des
textes votés ici au sénat à l'assemblée
nous avons été moteur ici au sénat de
cette initiative et avec souvent il ya
une fin de non recevoir du gouvernement
pour des raisons qui étaient plus des
raisons philosophiques ou considérant
que cette délégation qui se rapprochait
des minima sociaux
nos arguments étaient soutenus par
l'ensemble des essais sur du monde du
handicap par pratiquement tous les
groupes politiques ici au sénat et à
l'occasion du texte concernant le
pouvoir d'achat et du projet de loi de
finances rectificatif il ya le
gouvernement change d'avis on avait
quand même quelques bruines on a un
public pendant la campagne électorale
avait été interpellé par des personnes
handicapées lui-même trouvé ça étrange
donc on est heureux que finalement ils
aient plus de temps peut-être de
discuter avec son gouvernement et qu'il
ait changé d'avis dans tous les cas ce
que l'on montre ce que l'on porte
finalement c'est que le sénat sert
finalement à porter des idées malgré des
sentiments parfois difficile du
gouvernement malgré des attitudes
négatives on voit que lorsqu'on prend
des idées lorsqu'on arguments des idées
et bien dans la durée on peut être amené
à voir des ouvertures évidemment changé
le principe général ou la vida
gouvernement changer pour que enfin bien
les personnes handicapées tout justice a
traversé imaginer que c'est une volonté
d'ouverture de la part du gouvernement
mais je crois surtout c'est assez
positif pour les personnes handicapées
qui ont le sentiment d'être entendu face
à cette mesure qui était rude et porté
par tous les groupes politiques en
dehors de la république comme un retour
que c'est un changement j'espère c'est
bonne augure pour l'avenir
[Musique]